novak djokovic ya no podrá defender su
título como ganador del abierto de
australia según las reglas del gran slam
la posición número 1 del cuadro ha sido
ocupada por el afortunado perdedor el
nombre de quien disputará los partidos
organizados para djokovic será revelado
este lunes la decisión de las
autoridades australianas podría tener
repercusiones en su carrera pues podría
ser vetado por tres años para entrar al
país lo que le impediría disputar de
nuevo el abierto pero en cuanto a la atp
el serbio seguirá siendo el número uno
del mundo los 11.000 puntos que tiene el
tenista en la clasificación general lo
mantendrá en este lugar por el momento
la atp que recomienda la vacunación de
todos sus jugadores
respaldó la decisión del gobierno
australiano
en última instancia las decisiones de
las autoridades legales en materia de
salud pública deben ser respetadas
independientemente de cómo se ha llegado
a este punto novak es uno de nuestros
mayores campeones y su ausencia en el
abierto de australia es una pérdida para
nuestro deporte
pero ante la exigencia de la vacunación
por parte de los países donde se juegan
los gran slams el futuro de djokovic no
se visualiza alentador en eeuu donde se
juega el usopen y en londres reino unido
donde se juega wimbledon exigen la pauta
completa para ingresar el único gran
torneo de la temporada que podría jugar
es el roland garros en francia ya que
según la ministra de salud de este país
los protocolos de salud en estos eventos
permitirían su participación si djokovic
existe no vacunarse también podría
perder la oportunidad de competir en
tres de los másters 1000 que se disputan
en eeuu